Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Recently, a new breed of AI techniques surfaced
that were capable of this new thing called
image translation.
And by image translation I mean that they
can translate a drawn map to a satellite image,
take a set of color labels and make a photorealistic
facade, or take a sketch and create a photo
out of it.
This is done through a Generative Adversarial
Network.
This is an architecture where we have a pair
of neural networks, one that learns to generate
new images, and the other learns to tell a
fake image from a real one.
As they compete against each other, they get
better and better without any human interaction.
In these earlier applications, unfortunately,
the output is typically one image, and since
there are many possible shoes that could satisfy
our initial sketch, it is highly unlikely
that the one we are offered is exactly what
we envisioned.
This improved version enhanced this algorithm
to be able to produce not one, but an entire
set of outputs.
And as you can see here, we have a night image,
and a set of potential daytime translations
on the right that are quite diverse.
I really like how it has an intuitive understanding
of the illumination differences of the building
during night and daytime.
It really seems to know how to add lighting
to the building.
It also models the atmospheric scattering
during daytime, creates multiple kinds of
pretty convincing clouds, or puts hills in
the background.
The results are both realistic, and the additional
selling point is that this technique offers
an entire selection of outputs.
What I found to be really cool about the next
comparisons is that ground truth images are
also attached for reference.
If we can take a photograph of a city at nighttime,
we have access to the same view during the
daytime too, or we can take a photograph of
a shoe and draw the outline of it by hand.
And as you can see here, there are not only
lots of high-quality outputs, but in some
cases, the ground truth image is really well
approximated by the algorithm.
This means that we give it a crude drawing,
and it could translate this drawing into a
photorealistic image that is very close to
reality.
I think that is mind blowing!
The validation section of the paper reveals
that this technique provides a great tradeoff
between diversity and quality.
There are previous methods that perform well
if we need one high-quality solution, or many
not so great ones, but overall this one provides
a great package for artists working in the
industry, and this will be a godsend for any
kind of content generation scenario.
The source code of this project is also available,
and make sure to read the license before starting
your experiments.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!